g'day there managing weeds is
unfortunately a part of land ownership
many weeds are highly invasive and can
quickly overtake land they can have a
devastating impact on agriculture and
ecosystems that can also cause severe
illness in both people and animals so
for better or worse you have an
obligation to control them under the
biosecurity act 2015. the good news is
that weeds can be controlled and there
are resources available to guide your
weed management here are a few quick
tips have practices in place to prevent
weeds from entering your property these
include having a holding paddock or yard
area dedicated to receiving new
livestock so that weed seeds can be
eliminated from animals having a
dedicated well-equipped area for washing
down and cleaning vehicles and farm
machinery and knowing where your fodder
is coming from and ensuring that it's
weed free simple measures can all help
stop wheat spread it's important to
control weeds before they seed or spread
after rain and during spring are key
times for weed control it's useful to
get out and have a walk around your
place regularly to look for any
incursions particularly around
watercourses and boundaries also check
out any feed distribution areas or
locations where new stock have been if
you notice any new or suspect species
check the department of primary
industries we wise app for tips on
identification and management or contact
your local authority these are usually
your local council identifying what
weeds you have in the paddock is key to
an effective control program
some control techniques are not
appropriate for all weed species so you
need to know what you're starting with
and have a plan again check out the new
south wales dpi website or contact your
local authority for control advice until
next time cheers
[Music]